mes chers amis
le président nicolas sarkozy
a pris l'initiative en début d'année
de constituer un comité des mères
au moment où
nous avons le sentiment
que la démocratie locale et malmené
il était
indispensable
mais aussi réconfortant
de pouvoir revenir nos voix
pour nous adresser au gouvernement
commun l'ensemble des françaises et des
français
pour leur faire part de notre
détermination
à défendre nos territoires
nos communes qui sont les piliers de
notre démocratie
dans ce comité
constitué
des maires de toutes les strates des
communes de france à la fois urbaine
périurbaine rural
nous portons tous
une même ambition
celle de
lancer aujourd'hui
un véritable cri d'alarmé
et de dire à l'état socialiste
ça n'est plus possible
nous faisons tous
le kostek notre relation avec l'état
c'est aujourd'hui considérablement
dégradée
et les maires
la somme le des élus locaux
que des fins si bien dans notre
mouvement mon collègue et ami jean
rottner le maire de mulhouse
sont non seulement inquiet
mais aussi en colère
nous avons mes amis le sentiment que la
démocratie locale et elle est même
menacée
il est urgent de refonder les relations
entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
il existe aujourd'hui entre le pouvoir
central et les collectivités une très
forte tension
ce n'est pas simplement due aux
conséquences de la crise financière
préfon fortes tensions qui tiennent
avant tout au fait que l'état ne tient
pas ses engagements
et surtout aussi à la perte de confiance
à l'insécurité juridique et financière
qui en résulte dans nos communes
mais jamie les élus locaux sont avant
tout des acteurs publics responsables
il exige d'être reconnu comme tel
personne aujourd'hui ne conteste la
nécessité
de baisser les déficits publics
mais l'effort qui nous ce qui nous est
demandé sur nos territoires est
aujourd'hui totalement n'est supportable
de 2014 à 2017
les dotations de l'état aux
collectivités territoriales seront
amputés de 30% or c'est le bloc communal
qui est de loin le plus touché alors que
toutes les études démontrent que c'est
cet échelon qui aiment v6 le plus
aujourd'hui sur le territoire
les conséquences sur l'économie seront
catastrophiques
mais pas uniquement sur l'économie cette
situation est désastreuse désastreuses
pour l'emploi pour la cohésion sociale
pour la solidarité pour l'éducation pour
la culture
nous allons devoir remettre en cause des
services de proximité indispensable la
population et c'est le tissu associatif
qui sera le premier pénaliser
l'investissement des communes nous le
savons c'est un 10 c'est un
indispensable moteur de la croissance or
dès 2017 nombreuses seront celles qui
n'auront plus et qui ne pompent plus
s'autofinancer alors oui mes amis nous
avons vos conquis des villes des
villages
l'année dernière nous venons de
reconquérir des départements
nous allons reconquérir en décembre
prochain et région auquel plus de dix
ans de gestion socialiste ont fait tant
de mal avec les républicains nous allons
faire entendre la voix des territoires
pour cannes 2010 cet ensemble nous
fassions de gagner la france